stuttgart der unbequeme gast auf bayerns
meister party der vfb von akuter
relegations angst und abstiegssorgen
geplagt die münchner zwischen ybbs und
meisterschalen übergabe fahrig und
fehlerhaft tiago thomas schmid der
stuttgarter für hoffnung beim tabellen
16 die münchner nur selten mit guten
ideen gabri
marokkaners ring den ball zum ausgleich
ins eigene tor bayern liegt nach thomas
müller wie es eben nur ein thomas müller
21 bayern durch den ur bayer die zweite
hälfte leidenschaftliche stuttgarter so
sascha eingabe karadzic 2 zu 2 neues mut
und schwäbischer jubel ein tor das im
abstiegskampf noch gold wert sein kann
die nachspielzeit in einem spiel der
leidenschaft command schwarzen gegen
afro panoz aytekin zeit glatt groß der
letzte akt in münchen 22 am ende
stuttgart darf weiter hoffen
der fc bayern feiert die zehnte deutsche
meisterschaft in serie für julia
nagelsmann der erste zieht
führt verabschiedet sich vor heimischer
kulisse von der bundesliga und vor der
partie gegen dortmund von trainer stefan
leitl in einem chancenarmen ersten
durchgang nutzte der bvb die erste
gelegenheit der aero linde dran brand
der ball drin 10 dortmund
nach dem seitenwechsel das spiel besser
in gang kam erstes saisontor zum 1 1
technisch hochklassig jedoch nicht mehr
eins ein kleiner trost für den
tabellenletzten julian brandt dortmunds
beste an diesem spieltag kurz darauf zum
2 2 1 für den bvb der in diesem spiel
wie so häufig in dieser saison nicht
immer seine ganze klasse auf den rasen
bringen kann der eingewechselte passt
zum 3 1 für schwarz-gelb gleichzeitig
der endstand der bvb sichert sich damit
die vizemeisterschaft zum achten mal
insgesamt freude kommt es hat trotzdem
nicht auf
schüler hoeneß hoffenheimer ist das
spiel gegen leverkusen die letzte chance
auf das europäische geschäft hüther
schürt die hoffenheimer hoffnung mit den
eins zu null die werkself mit einem sieg
sicher in der königsklasse antwortet
schick eins zu eins die tsg keineswegs
geschockt von gartner nach kardex
vorarbeit mit dem 2 1 für die
kraichgauer
beide mannschaften bieten auch in der
zweiten hälfte beste
fußball-unterhaltung
diaby mit dem erneuten ausgleich für
bayer es folgt der große auftritt des
patrick schick schick wendig eiskalt 32
leverkusen der 24 saisontreffer des
tschechen einfach stark den schlusspunkt
setzte der eingewechselte mario um 4 zu
2 bayer leverkusen dreht das spiel in
hoffenheim und sichert sich den einzug
in die königsklasse
party trotz pleite fc-kapitän hector am
boden köln und modells trotzdem auf
wolke und sicher platzieren die
europacup teilnahme gesichert der
ex-kölner janicki hat erzählt er diesen
denkwürdigen nachmittag nach wien zu
spiel den entscheidenden treffer in
einem emotionalen spiel das der vfl
wolfsburg am ende mit 1 0 gewinnt da
auch hoffenheim verliert steigt am rhein
die große party der fc spielt nach fünf
jahren abstinenz nächste saison wieder
international
die aufschrift auf unions t shirts etwas
kryptisch am ende der partie zwischen
freiburg und den eisernen ist die
bedeutung klar union berlin spielt
nächste saison wieder international wie
auch der sportclub die köpenicker mit
einer überzeugenden leistung der starke
beckstein an den pfosten krümmel zum 1 0
für die gäste
der mögliche ausgleichstreffer von
hühner wird wegen eines angeblichen
handspiels des freiburger angreifers
durch schiedsrichter durch annuliert
streichs reaktionen auf die entscheidung
entsprechend
auf der gegenseite dekkers hereingabe
findet trimmel 20 union nach 41 minuten
steht es dann sogar 13 0 für die
eisernen schermbecker fertig und eiskalt
nach dem seitenwechsel der freiburg
schüler dann jubeln das 1 3 aus sicht
der preis gehören den schlusspunkt setzt
wieder union der eingewechselte schäfer
nach einer sehenswerten einzelaktion zum
4 2 1 endstand trotz der freiburger
niederlage auch hier die botschaft
eindeutig europa erreicht
für bielefeld ist das gastspiel beim vfl
bochum der letzte strohhalm um noch
irgendwie den klassenerhalt zu sichern
doch bochum ist von beginn an die
druckvollere mannschaft toll dass
führungstreffer nach pankow hereingabe
die logische konsequenz der vfl
verpasste es nachzulegen und kassiert
noch vor der pause dafür die quittung
kassen freistoß von endet nilsson zum
ausgleich die 89 minute bielefeld
strohhalm und die hoffnung auf den
klassenerhalt fast weg sommer frei vor
ort arminia bello ins eigene tor 2 1
bochum bielefeld schlägt sich selbst und
braucht nun ein wunder der abstieg für
das team von marco kostmann rückt immer
näher
felix magath und die hertha haben es
gegen mainz selbst in der hand den
klassenerhalt zu sichern doch es kommt
anders mainz geht durch wittmann in der
ersten hälfte in führung jk im berliner
zoo kurzes eck wohl doch nicht immer das
eck des torhüters die nachspielzeit des
ersten durchgangs selke per strafstoß
nach videobeweis zum ausgleich mainz
gewinnt am ende nicht unverdient mit 2 1
bell setzt per kopf den schlusspunkt
trotz der niederlage und dem verpassten
matchball persönliche bilder in der
hauptstadt am samstagabend ist der
endgültige klassenerhalt noch nicht
sicher durch bayerns remis gegen
stuttgart muss härter am 34 spieltag auf
die endgültige rettung hoffen
in der liga geht es für die eintracht
nicht mehr um die wurst das ziel der
titel in der europa league frankfurts
b-elf wird von gladbach eiskalt erwischt
leider auf player 10 für die borussia
für die es ebenfalls um nicht mehr viel
in der liga geht es die zweite hälfte
passieren der sonntagsschuss am sonntag
zum 1 1 endstand
das highlights einer sonst eher
verhaltenen angelegenheit
augsburg nimmt vor dem spiel in leipzig
glückwünsche zum klassenerhalt an der
fca am sonntagabend durch das
stuttgarter remy zuvor in münchen
gerettet das spiel zunächst kaum
mitreißend die erste hälfte teleskops
weckruf an seine mannschaft nicht
schlafen und nur von der champions
league träumen
silber mit dem 1 0 für die sachsen ein
tor als wachmacher in der zweiten hälfte
erhöhte
nach vorarbeit von nico ihle auf 2 0 das
13 0 dann wieder eine co produktion der
beiden franzosen im kuko mit seinem
zwanzigster saisontreffer leipzig stark
augsburg enttäuschend forsberg per
strafstoß zum 4 0 endstand
leipzig hat im rennen um die champions
league wieder gut lachen
die ergebnisse des 32
spieltages in der übersicht meister
bayern nur 2 2 gegen stuttgart
leverkusen leipzig und union feiern
wichtige siege im hinblick auf das
europäische geschäft bielefeld verliert
den bochum mainz gewinns in berlin die
tabelle bayern vor vize meister dortmund
leverkusen sicher in der champions
league light sich neuer vierter vor
freiburg köln siebter am tabellenende
hat augsburg fünf punkte vorsprung auf
platz 16 und ist damit gerettet härter
vor stuttgart am 34 spieltag im
fernduell um den relegationsplatz
bielefeld als siebzehnter so gut wie
abgestiegen
[Musik]